down in the Mitchell slide or the saw oh
okay Justin yeah I don't think he's
doing - I think he's just gonna raise it
he's gonna raise it higher but said to
me Zach when you raise the rent it
actually goes to get your advantage
because you're not doing as much if the
rim is higher
what about Kenny the fact that his first
dunk he's going to do something like
this I said he got everybody's attention
he got mine okay
I wonder how they don't be vote cuz I'm
never shackled oh yeah make the first
one
he's gonna throw it off the backboard no
first bag okay
cool
[Applause]
has a wall behind
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
he can't do the two ball now a traitor
yes crater yes this is what Dan says it
was a little bit harder than you thought
yeah the pops made it look so easy
pops made it look so easy straight leg
[Applause]
like father like son
yeah yeah I mean actually I like to see
you side by side I'd like to see what do
we have there because Jordan actually
took that cradle dumps to another level
everybody remembers these are what those
dunks you have to say it's nice the
extra sauce at the end the show me show
me door
okay let's chat with a little stuff
[Applause]
[Music]
this is crazy with the mask on it's
tough yeah the slow-motion reaction at
this dump the tomahawk to a windmill is
what he'll be finished with a little pop
[Applause]
I think you might have some more hands
because that's crazy
he's so he
[Applause]
but no look at the degree that's great
that's great he's going to opposite way
yeah that's gone against which his hands
fitting with the lay you're right hey
[Music]
just scrunch down
he's already scrunch down like that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
why did he try to do the column alone I
think he brought it out now he ain't
missing all partners no way I think he
brought that he just did tap it off the
back
[Music]
at the 720 into the 720 Bonham estate
bioethicist
first attempt here for Donovan Mitchell
there we go
[Applause]